is robert pattinson the best actor to
play the caped crusader in live action
does kevin conroy still reign supreme
when it comes to batman voice actors and
where does adam west draw straight man
figure into it all these are the movie
versions of batman ranked worst the best
the thing you really have to understand
about the original batman serials is
that they're bad not just bad in
retrospect after 70 years of
advancements in filmmaking and special
effects although they certainly fit that
bill pretty handily no they're just bad
the first serial released by colombia in
15 parts amounts to four and a half
hours of the worst version of batman to
ever hit the silver screen batman and
robin played by lewis wilson and douglas
croft a recast as government agents who
joined up to help a war effort and are
tasked with stopping the villainous
doctor dhaka from building a death
threat in theory that's a pretty
exciting plot unfortunately the actual
execution is atrocious it somehow winds
up being repetitive even by the
standards of serials with alarmingly bad
special effects hilariously awkward
costumes unconvincing fights and of
course a massive helping of racism to
bring it all together overall this is a
batman best forgotten
the best thing you can say about 1949's
batman and robin is that it's not as
racist as its predecessor unfortunately
that's about all you can say robert
lowry's batman stumbles from one goopy
cliffhanger to the next in an attempt to
unmask a mad scientist called the wizard
four hours later it turns out to be
exactly who you thought he was we'll
take hilariously silly over upsettingly
racist any day of the week but the fact
remains that lowry's bumbling barely
present batman is trapped in a pretty
awful plot that stretches out even
longer than the first cereal the worst
part though is that costume a
straight-up sweatsuit capped off with an
ill-fitting cowl
every now and then an idea comes along
that seems like an absolute no-brainer
such is the case with the casting of
peter weller as the older batman drawn
out of retirement in the animated
adaptation of frank miller's
groundbreaking dark knight returns it
sounds so good on paper right an older
more brutal and even angrier batman
played by the guy who brought his voice
to the title role of robocop it's such a
perfect idea that it's hard to argue
that they should have done anything else
unfortunately the idea is the only part
that's perfect whether it's weller's
unfamiliarity with the art of voice
acting or the desired effect from
director j olivia while her sounds in
every scene like he just woke up he
might actually be the worst part of the
film rather than a dynamic growl that
goes with the action weller winds up
just being boring and whatever problems
you might have with the dark knight
returns boring should not be one of them
you're slow
true but we're all slow when we're third
even mud
bruce greenwood can best be described as
the 2003 toyota corolla of batman actors
nothing fancy no real features to speak
of and it doesn't quite have the appeal
of the older classic models or newer
better ones but it'll get you where
you're going okay so maybe that's a
harsh way of putting it but it's pretty
accurate
greenwood has played batman on multiple
occasions three dtv movies a video game
and the young justice tv show and it's
probably telling that there's only one
of those the adaptation of gotham by
gaslight where he's the focus
even then the emphasis is less on batman
as a character than it is on the idea of
seeing all the familiar characters
recast in the victorian era setting of a
story in which batman fights jack the
ripper the others are all focused on
different characters and in the case of
under the red hood greenwood is playing
batman opposite supernatural star jensen
ackles whose performance is jason todd
is so full of charisma that he quickly
upstages his co-star
you don't understand
i don't think you've ever understood
what
what your moral code just won't allow
for that
since actor jensen ackles did such a
bang-up job as jason todd in 2010's
animated adaptation of under the red
hood he got his chance as a caped
crusader himself in a pair of long
halloween adaptations in 2021
unfortunately echols showed his talents
weren't quite the fit for batman that
many had anticipated eccles delivers a
stock standard wayne and slightly
gruffier dark knight
attacking us like that out in the open
it didn't fit the profile
troy baker ironically enough becomes a
hero of this adaptation by giving an
excellent haml impersonation as the
joker david de small chin likewise
offers up a genuinely chilling
performance here as calendar man this
arc features most of batman's rogue's
gallery appearing in one way or another
each character playing their own small
role if you're a batman fan it's a must
watch just don't expect ackle's work
here to give you any new insights into
the character
on paper ben affleck seems like a pretty
solid choice for batman he's got those
square jawed good looks and he's more
than capable of bringing a deep focus
and intensity to roles when they call
for it in practice though the batman of
dawn of justice is only saved from being
the worst superhero in his universe
because superman is somehow even worse
it's worth noting that much of director
zack snyder's inspiration came from
frank miller's landmark story the dark
knight returns unfortunately while the
movie recreated entire scenes wholesale
from the comics they're all divorced
from their original context affleck's
batman is a ludicrously violent murderer
who's easily manipulated into a fist
fights with another superhero a fist
fight that ends when the person he's
fighting reminds him that other people
also have moms you'd think that would be
something he would have learned in his
years as the world's greatest detective
[Music]
the animated adaptation of frank miller
and dave matsukelli's batman year one
fares a little better than the dark
knight returns for a few reasons but the
casting of its title character was not
one of them then mckenzie approaches the
role of a young bruce wayne trying to
figure out how to best fight crime with
what can only be described as the
monotone delivery of a sexy robot
seriously we've tried to think of other
ways to describe it but that is
unquestionably the best one
you've eaten well
you've eaten gotham's wealth
it's spirit
but your feast is nearly over
all of the intensity and emotion of key
scenes from the original like being
inspired by the bat crashing through his
window or announcing his presence to
gotham's wealthy white-collar criminals
is lost in favor of the central monotony
of some kind of pleasure droid once you
have that image in your head it does
make mackenzie's batman a little more
interesting but it doesn't rescue the
performance instead ironically enough
batman winds up being overshadowed by
another year one main character jim
gordon who's played here by brian
cranston in a role that mckenzie would
get a few years later as the star of
gotham it's been years since i had to
take out a green beret
even so he deserves a handicap
crisis on two earths was one of the
earlier entries into the ever expanding
roster of dc universe animated original
movies and generally speaking it's also
one of the best it was loosely based on
some classic jla stories giving it a
solid foundation it was written by the
late dwayne mcduffie who was the story
editor for justice league unlimited he
even has some great fight scenes and
solid visuals that are a step above what
viewers would get later in fact pretty
much everything about the movie is great
except batman it was a weird bit of
stunt casting to get william baldwin to
play the dark knight but he's not really
bad in the part he just never really
sounds like batman in a way that's
difficult to pin down what was so
valuable that the crime syndicate would
cross dimensions to get it did you keep
it from her her henchmen escaped with it
whatever it was maybe it's just that
this feels like a lost episode of
justice league which makes it a little
weird that it's not kevin conroy's voice
coming out of batman maybe it's that
this appears to be baldwin's very first
voice acting gig giving him some
intangible quality that sounds a little
off whatever it is it's just not quite
right
2021 soul of the dragon is another
modern dc animated outing that recasts
the dark knight and it has a lot of good
things going for it even if the least
impressive of them is its take on batman
grim actor david gentoli gives a dry
performance as bruce wayne his batman
doesn't bear much less grim in the rare
instances he dons the cape at all the
movie focuses as much on mark to costco
as doing his best bruce lee impression
as richard dragon as it does on bruce
wayne we're in this together bruce
just like we've always been
like we're supposed to be
we
are the dragon this original batman
story was written by animated series
veteran bruce tim set in the 1970s solo
the dragon is an r-rated like take on
martial arts films inspired largely by
the bruce lee classic enter the dragon
of course it takes cues from the martial
arts heavy batman begins as well overall
though soul of the dragon is a pretty
good animated homage if not necessarily
a great batman movie
the best way to describe agents of
shield actor jason omaro's take on
batman is this what would it sound like
if george clooney had been allowed to be
batman in a much less campy setting
omaro's tone of voice is remarkably
similar to how clooney sounded behind
the cowl even if he isn't allowed to
embrace his charisma as fully as clooney
could the story of hush is a strong one
as batman must uncover the identity of a
mysterious new killer in gotham however
omara delivers a confident only slightly
brooding take on the detective
the events of the past months reach as
high as superman and as low as the joker
all were set into motion by hush
omaro would come back for 2020 solid
justice league dark apocalypse war where
he reprised his role alongside a
star-studded cast and a very different
very violent sort of superhero story but
unfortunately omaro's second shot at the
character wasn't enough to put him any
higher on this list
first things first diedrich bader is
actually a really good batman in batman
the brave and the bold he served as a
cheerless batman his take was as a
straight man for a cast of super heroic
oddballs in a series of team-ups that
span the entirety of the dc universe
even the viewers who were initially put
off by the show's inherent silliness
were won over when the show veered into
darkness with chill of the night
so just like that he signed away their
lives
so casually without remorse without
blinking a filthy eye here's the problem
there's no brave and the bold movie to
show up bader's chops although he does
get second billing in a
straight-to-video scooby-doo movie that
just leaves jla adventures trapped in
time the story revolves around the
justice league having to go back in time
to save baby superman from being
murdered by the legion of doom at one
point it involves him literally throwing
the indestructible kryptonian baby
around like a football overall though
it's pretty forgettable outside of some
truly bad costume designs and none of
the things that made bader's batman work
on display
in the run-up to the release of 2019's
joker there was a lot of commentary
about how writer-director todd phillips
had said that his take on the title
character with joaquin phoenix didn't
follow anything from the comic books
with that being the case it was probably
pretty embarrassing for him to realize
that he accidentally put both the joker
and bruce wayne who was actually the
comic book superhero batman into the
film sure technically the little boy
bruce wayne doesn't suit up as a dark
avenger of the night to perform any of
the ninja tricks batman is known for but
we're still counting him for this list
in fact dante pereira olsen gives us an
interesting bass line for bat
performances he definitely doesn't do
anything wrong in his portrayal of
little batman but that's mostly because
he doesn't really do anything period his
most memorable moment in the film comes
in a scene during which bruce stands
there silently while a grown man puts
his fingers into bruce's mouth and makes
him smile pereira olsen is perfectly
fine for what he's been given to do
which is nothing and the end result is
that this is the bat performance
equivalent to pure water a completely
value neutral baseline that we can use
as our midpoint
in virtually any other film casting
jimmy kimmel as batman would be
downright alarming for fans provoking
the kind of discourse that would make
ben affleck getting the part look like a
brief but civil debate in teen titans go
to the movies however it's not even in
the top 5 most notable casting choices
the big one is almost certainly nicholas
cage's all too brief performance is
superman both because cage was initially
set to play the man of steel and tim
burton superman lives and because it's
nicholas cage as superman i knew you
were goofsters but using lois and now
this it's too much
compared to that kimmel as batman
doesn't seem all that notable or to be
honest all that memorable despite batman
being at the center of one of the film's
most notable moments kimmel is
ultimately very forgettable as batman
it's that rare case of a movie that just
has too much going on
in a movie that's soaked in lime green
neon and hot pink leopard print val
kilmer's portrayal of the cape crusader
is well the kindest way to put it would
be reserved but let's not mince words
here kilmer only two years removed from
a charismatic scene-stealing turn as
dock holiday and tombstone drifts
through batman forever with the screen
presence of a cardboard cutout
what's wrong
to be fair there was a good reason for
him to make that choice as an actor
director joel schumacher tim burton's
hand-picked successor was clearly
drawing his inspiration from the 1966
television show and with jim carrey and
tommy lee jones chewing their way
through every available bit of scenery
replicating adam west's straight man so
they'd have something to bounce off of
probably seemed like the best way to go
there are parts where it actually works
too the best scenes by far in batman
forever are the ones in which carries
edward nigma tries to dress act and
sound like his idol kilmer's bruce wayne
for those he's the perfect straight man
for the wildly over-the-top villains
when it comes to actually being batman
however kilmer's adam west impression
just doesn't land whether it's battling
against the villains giving dick grayson
a home or having a monumentally tepid
romance with nicole kidman's dr chase
meridian it just flat out doesn't work
if you're not familiar with batman
unlimited that's probably because it's
the reverse of the way things usually
work rather than starting out with a
movie or cartoon and then creating toys
based on that this one started out as an
action figure line that was created to
keep kid-friendly batman toys in stores
during the more pg-13 era of the
christopher nolan and zack snyder films
once the toys were out a series of
animated shorts and a trio of
direct-to-video movies were released and
if you're into the weirder side of
batman they're well worth watching you
might expect a movie that only exists to
support an action figure line to feature
a series of incredibly toyotic costumes
but the unlimited movies go a step
further by giving batman a new sidekick
in the form of a robot wolf that turns
into a motorcycle they're not exactly
what you'd call good but they are
awesome i am shooting a viral video here
batman is brought to life this time
courtesy of veteran voice actor roger
craig smith it might seem
counterintuitive to cast the same guy
who played sonic the hedgehog and thomas
from regular show as batman but he turns
in a solid performance he definitely
shows why he was brought back to play
the caped crusader in other projects
like the english dub of batman ninja and
most recently 2020 superman red sun
to say batman and robin has a bad
reputation is putting it about as mildly
as you possibly could whether or not it
deserves all the hate it's commonly
regarded as one of the worst superhero
movies of all time with a bloated cast
of villains and sidekicks sprawling out
into a plot that starts off silly and
ends up verging on ludacris
i hate to disappoint you but
rubber lips are immune to your charms
it's so bad that both joel schumacher
and george clooney have apologized for
it and it was credited with nearly
killing the franchise until it returned
with a darker direction under
christopher nolan the thing is as
controversial as it might sound
clooney's not actually that bad in the
role of bruce wayne like affleck he's an
actor who was perfect for the role on
paper a leading man on the rise who
brought an effortless charm to the role
the problem is that effortless charm
doesn't really work for batman but it
ends up working pretty well for bruce
wayne clooney's best work comes when
he's out of the costume so even around
wayne manor dealing with albert's not
quite fatal illness or in the few scenes
where we see him as the franchise's most
convincing version of a celebrity
playboy to date
of all the actors to play batman troy
baker might be the most versatile he's
the only actor to voice both batman and
the joker in batman vs teenage mutant
ninja turtles he plays them both in the
same film and he's even been three
different versions of robin in other
movies he has range even has range
within the same character the version of
batman that he plays in the kid targeted
lego movies is a slightly different
character than we get from the more
serious version in batman vs teenage
mutant ninja turtles they're both
recognizably baker who manages to carve
out a performance that's a little more
distinct from other voice actors the
only real downside is that he often
comes off as a substitute for other
actors his joker for instance is very
much filling in for more camel and his
batman could be seen as a replacement
for kevin conroy still baker's batman is
incredibly solid he captures the
threatening growl of the dark knight
while still having enough energy and
character to keep it from slipping into
monotone it's arguable that his
performance is what makes batman vs tmnt
work far better than it had any right to
reno romano's tenure on the animated
show the batman despite lasting a
respectable five seasons will always
exist in the shadow of its predecessor
batman the animated series and will
never be as fondly remembered that's a
shame too he might not be as definitive
as kevin conroy but romano is actually
very good in the part as a younger
batman romano's got a little more
lightness and energy to his performance
but still keeps a gravelly menace that
comes along with the cape and cowl
romano's one full-length adventure the
spooky made for tv the batman vs dracula
is an enjoyable movie in its own right
and even works as a showcase for the
redesigned penguin and joker still for
the epic confrontation between the
bat-themed good guy and a vampire bad
guy it's not quite as good as you want
it to be especially since that story has
been told with more panache elsewhere
that's romano's role in a nutshell if we
didn't have anything to compare it to
and could judge it entirely on its own
merits he'd be great
director matt reeves took a big chance
in casting an actor many viewers mainly
know as a twilight vampire robert
pattinson but as the months of
production went by the concept of
pattinson batman one of her fans
pattinson's bruce wayne is not only
younger looking than fans have come to
expect from the character but he's also
decidedly more awkward around people in
case the nirvana needle drops didn't get
the point across this man is filled with
angst regret and a healthy dose of
self-loathing he clings to his virtuous
vigilante mission as batman referring to
himself as a nocturnal animal determined
to clean up the streets in a film
heavily influenced by 70's cinema will
he soar like brewster macleod or go off
the deep end like travis pickle as
batman pattinson's jaw is the best since
kilmer but his quirky decisions and
physicality feel more like michael
keaton without the tim burton polish
this is a world's greatest detective who
makes mistakes gets teased over the
declaration
i'm vengeance
and punctuates a daring escape by
deploying his parachute too quickly and
slamming into the pavement he's flawed
and that's interesting
there's a moment in batman begins that
really captures the intensity christian
bale brings to his performance as batman
where were the other drugs going
i never knew i don't know
i swear to god swear to me
bale's batman brings that intensity to
everything he does showing an emotional
range that stretches from the righteous
fury of batman to the aimless pain of
the orphaned bruce wayne it's a power
that's only ever matched when he goes up
against heath ledger's joker one of the
best performances in the genre the
detective part of the package might be a
little lacking but the way bale plays
off his co-stars and paints a picture of
a man torn between using his rage to
fuel his mission and letting it consume
him is genuinely incredible the fact
that he does it all while speaking in a
voice that sounds like he's chewing
rusty nails that's just icing on the
cake
unlike every other actor on this list
will fridael doesn't play bruce wayne he
plays terry mcginnis a teenager from a
cyberpunk future who takes over the role
in batman beyond along with a killer
costume design and the best version of a
retired bruce wayne fredel's performance
is one of the biggest reasons why batman
beyond works the way that he switches
from terry's normal lighter speaking
voice to the growly batman voice that he
uses is distinct without ever feeling
like he's going too far over the top of
it he's also an extremely likable
character in a way that bruce is batman
never really is carrie seems more like a
human being and less like the peak ideal
of human perfection who is also very
grumpy about it the only thing that's
holding him back is that his only film
appearance comes in batman beyond return
of the joker which has a very different
tone from the batman beyond tv series
it's one of the darkest things that dc
has ever done with their animated
properties to the point where some
pretty graphic scenes were heavily
edited for its first release that said
it's still a well done and extremely
engaging movie it's just not a good
showcase of what makes freddell and
terry so good in their roles
the tim burton batman movies have an
incredible visual style with a gotham
city that's hellish urban sprawl come to
life full of buildings with exposed
ductwork and piping stacked up next to
art deco sculptures they're also full of
great bits of satire beautiful shots and
amazingly offbeat casts whether they're
good batman movies is a point of debate
and no one really captures that
disconnect more than michael keaton he's
actually kind of perfect for the kind of
remote mysterious weirdo who sleeps
upside down because he wants to be more
like a bat now you want to get nuts come
on let's get nuts but there's a
disconnect between the stylized
goopiness that burton explored in his
earlier films and the 80s action movie
aesthetic that saw keaton's batman
throwing people off buildings and
blowing up factories with bombs it's not
really portrayed as heroism but as a
personal quest for vengeance that only
incidentally winds up saving the city
keaton does well in the role but is
batman is missing some key components
other versions of the character nail
an ultra competent self-absorbed
superhero who writes heavy metal songs
about being a sad orphan and is
seemingly able to appear at will as soon
as no one's looking the lego version of
batman is one of those rare finds a
parody of something that actually works
pretty well as the thing itself
batman is very wise
i also have huge packs and a nine pack
yeah i've got an extra app willownet's
batman only builds things out of black
bricks and arnett ramps up his naturally
gravelly voice in a spoof of christian
bales at the same time though he's very
rarely presented as anything other than
extremely good at what he does and he
really does act heroically even if his
heroism occasionally means that han solo
gets eaten by a space worm either way it
works while other portrayals might move
away from the inherent silliness of the
character embracing it gives the lego
version a flavor that helps him rival
even the best of his big screen
contemporaries
the best thing about adam west
performance is batman is that it can
mean completely different things
depending on when you watch it as a
child it's easy to buy wes spandex clad
squareness as completely genuine as an
adult you get the joke the fact that he
was able to play the perfect straight
man for a wild cast of villains is every
bit as astonishing as those surface
level comic book thrills the 1966 movie
released between the first two seasons
of the batman tv series has everything
in a very literal sense the arch
villains are four of his greatest foes
brought together as a united underworld
complete with a sequence in which batman
and robin identify their enemies through
truly profound leaps of logic
but wait it happened at c
c
c for catwoman it also features west
using the role of bruce wayne as an
attempt to draw his enemies out into the
open miraculously turning his carefully
modulated tone into barely controlled
rage at the threat of his love interest
miss kitka and the heartbreak in his
eyes when he discovers that she was
catwoman all along it's a surprisingly
powerful moment no actor has ever been
as strongly identified with the role of
batman as adam west and the movie shows
exactly why his performance walks the
delicate balance between full-hearted
adventure and witty satire that the
material does and the end result is
perfect
yes this one is a bit of a cheat kevin
conroy has after all been the most
prominent batman actor for over 25 years
making his debut on batman the animated
series and staying in the role in many
of the dc animated movies and the arkham
video games but there's a good reason
conroy is an amazing batman and
everything that makes him great is on
display and mask of the phantasm one of
the great things about the animated
series was that it gave us a version of
batman that was already fully formed
saving the origin stories for a handful
of villains like two-face and the
riddler for the film though the origin
story is a crucial component and
conroy's performance sells it
beautifully the scene when he's standing
in front of his parents graves pleading
with them to understand he may give up
being batman because he's finally found
happiness might sound ridiculous but in
practice it's devastatingly emotional i
know i made a promise
but i didn't see this coming
i didn't count on being happy when that
happiness is taken away and batman gives
himself over to his mission entirely
it's fantastic for a generation of
batman fans conroys is the voice they
hear in their heads when they read the
comics and that alone should show just
how great he was it takes an incredible
amount of talent to redefine the
character but conroy did it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you